[Music]
starting your episode on a star field
just to make me jealous of places with
little to no light pollution i want to
see the universe civilization stop
progressing already show keeps matthew
modine completely shrouded in darkness
for the first 30 seconds making us wait
a full half minute to sin his hair its
behavior is predictable
like
all
animals it eats i mean sure but not all
animals eat children and even more
importantly not all animals live in a
parallel mirror dimension so your
predictions can go suck a slug here's
what's gonna happen character in
captivity tells their captors exactly
what's going to happen before exactly
the thing they said would happen happens
exactly the way they said it would
happen cliche you let me enjoy spires go
you're gonna give us anything we need
and we're gonna find her son
and then we're gonna forget
that any of this ever happened this is
the dumbest deal in the history of
bartering and there's no way the modine
mafia would agree to it honest hopper
expect to convince joyce to not expose
the bastards that faked the death of her
son how does he explain to the people of
discount haddenfield that will byers has
returned from the dead there's bluffing
then there's bluffing when you haven't
seen your cards then there's bluffing
when you haven't seen your cards and
you've never played poker before and
then there's this gun loading hammering
more gun loading trap setting even more
gun loading home improvement also
shooting a close-up of how many bullets
your gun holds when you don't intend on
counting to six later also also thinking
you can home alone a monster from the
underworld
you gotta give me your word
on those other three kids those boys
you're gonna leave them alone
and i'll tell you somehow jaded and
pissed at the world sheriff hopper
believes that the shady government
people conducting experiments on stolen
children are also people likely to be
worried about keeping promises
also if hopper knows how badly brenner
wants a levine back why didn't he
leverage him for more help than just two
hazard suits and a will went that away
the atmosphere is toxic all right my
son's in there joyce would be an 11 out
of 10 at tv sins it's trolls
thinking trolls would choose to hunt in
playgrounds for food instead of the
youtube comments section or whatever the
80s equivalent would have been you okay
i mean i'm wondering through a gooey
hellscape looking for my son who may or
may not be dead from toxic exposure
after being kidnapped by the demon
offspring of a venus flytrap and a very
angry horse but other than that i'm just
swell you i get that the floating
particles add some distinguishing
eeriness to the upside down but where is
it coming from and why is it constant
does the sky have dandruff do all the
creatures just have severe eczema is it
always winter and never christmas did
you hear that it's just the wind just
the wind tornadoes are just the wind man
wind can mess you up do you even wizard
of oz bro nancy
getting knock blocked
get out she points the loaded gun at him
and [ __ ] it that's dumb nancy's dumb or
the show is dumb or the show is dumb for
making nancy so dumb what's it doing
asking a question to a room full of
people who have exactly the same
information that you do excessive and
inexcusable egg examination is
excretable yet exhaustingly expected
everything in the upside down will
remind hopper of his child because
somehow it knows this is the season
finale and that the writers forgot to
finish telling us his backstory and for
pitysign not to ask her anymore
questions she said i must have asked her
a thousand already i suppose i had too
but how are you going to find things out
of a few nice questions ignoring
punctuation i mean if i delivered sins
like this wouldn't it be incredibly
distracting and difficult to follow
because commas mean how do they work and
actually we know how they work and allow
pauses so we can breathe in or give our
brain some time to catch up and process
what's being said someday somehow we're
supposed to believe that hopper reads
entire books to his child this way and
survives this
finally someone's acting reasonable in
getting the ever loving hell out of
hawkins the second the death creature
from another world shows up wish more of
these and he's about to go back in isn't
he the demogorgon will now play older
brother and pin jonathan to the ground
and hang slobber over him for a bit
before doing anything because that's
just basic predatory instinct more like
the demo borgin am i right what is the
number of the day time
one
two three four five
six
seven eight nine the number one
[Music]
showing off your bat spinning skills
instead of immediately killing the
flower-faced goo demon so the plan here
is to set the beast on fire for a few
seconds and then immediately put it out
i think that you want to save the house
but shouldn't you toast that sucker for
a little longer see marshmallows survive
longer than this
i has to be dead
yes the interdimensional being that can
inexplicably travel between your world
and its own is definitely dead don't you
dare let the lack of a body make you
think otherwise and of course hopper and
joyce arrive at the exact same hallway
where the kids just had the demogorgon
barbecue did they bring the graham
crackers and the chocolate bars for the
s'mores mike
i found the chocolate
dust is just the best she can make you
whatever you like that ghost
well
yeah it goes but real food too shut your
mouth keep that eggo shade out of my 80s
nostalgia thank you mike friends don't
lie but we do skip i know that just
following orders excuse doesn't mean
these are good people but i'm not
convinced they all deserve to have their
insides liquefied and that we should
still be expected to root for discount
dozen i mean she's responsible for more
recorded deaths than the demogorgon at
this point right 11
eleven can you hear me holding a barely
conscious child like this so that their
neck is supporting their entire body
what
what
what attempting to clarify your
statement by saying the exact same thing
wait where the [ __ ] did brenner go he
was literally holding his most prized
experiment did he seriously run for the
hills without taking her with him wait
he's still [ __ ] there so he saw the
demogorgon burst in dropped his weapon
of mass destruction got up and walked
directly towards the damn thing as if
he's meeting his date for the snowball
pulling this thing out seems like a
super risky move right they know the
environment's toxic so what if this is
acting as some sort of disgusting life
support system no one's suggesting you
leave him here but let's take a minute
to assess our options before
accidentally pulling his insides to the
outside
is it dead
asking a question to a room of people
who have exactly the same information
that you do also the demi lovato gorgons
haven't received nearly enough credit
for their impeccable sense of dramatic
timing
for a creature that was quickly pouncing
all the bad guys earlier the demogorgon
sure does like to showboat around these
kids huh fortunately i do not suffer
from photosensitive epilepsy but i
imagine this is a thoroughly unpleasant
experience for anyone that does if i
wanted to be flash this much i'd go to
mardi gras no more until the show
becomes a surprise hit then maybe we'll
need something for another season or two
but nothing that would age our actors
out of their parts for sure i mean
barring some sort of worldwide
pandemic uh pandemic this periodic table
includes a whole host of elements that
hadn't even been discovered in the 80s
including tennessee which wasn't
discovered until 2010 and [ __ ] you and
your fan fiction if you're going to come
at me saying the upside down is actually
a time portal to the future because it
[ __ ] isn't 29 30. now go
wait maybe the upside down is a time
portal because it clearly teleports
hopper 30 years into the future here
since he's counting out a 30 compression
cpr which wasn't even a thing until like
10 years ago before that it was like
five compressions or so between breaths
and even in hoppers flashback they're
screwing up the cpr because they clearly
show the ekg flat line later meaning she
already had a rhythm and cpr would be
counterproductive i made you a new
mixtape but didn't put a case on it
guess we know who the real monster is
now jonathan
this isn't causing will to scream in
agony after having his rib cage caved in
by hopper
[Music]
this is how 12 year olds talk about a
violent movie they saw it would not be
how they talk about real life trauma
they experienced so maybe back it down a
notch with the how cool was it when all
the heads exploded reported
sorry about the son of a [ __ ]
even back in the 80s the fireball spell
required the creature being attacked to
rolodice to see if they can dodge it so
mike should have rolled first instead of
letting will go straight for the damage
it's because he's had a near-death
experience doesn't mean you go easy on
him dude the campaign was way too short
yeah it was 10 hours but it doesn't make
any sense it makes sense oh no ah yes
the meaning of true fandom to criticize
the thing you love for being too short
too long over-explaining
under-explaining or just not exactly how
you would have written it but clearly
this is anachronistic considering
cinemasins didn't envision it picking
until 2012. can i open it
yeah sure no older brother has ever been
okay with her younger sibling opening a
christmas present from the girl they
have a crush on this is quite likely the
single most unbelievable thing in the
entire show you just had to put up some
news articles didn't you now i have to
read them so explain to me exactly what
you mean by experimentations in perusal
of mind control perusal did you mean
pursuit and sure this could have been a
typo but over here you've clearly got
the same paragraph twice these small
town newspaper editors are lazier than
the props department of a netflix show
are you okay
yeah i'm okay i could only assume that
will doesn't immediately tell his family
about his visions or the upslog down he
just coughed up for fear of being
sidelined for all of season 2 as well
we'll tell you about the game oh yeah i
threw a fire about him and
wait that's how you start that story not
only is that the big finish but your mom
has no context for who him even is or
why a fireball was needed that's
terrible storytelling will she get some
tips from matt and ross duffer
[Laughter]
matt and ross those may be the dumbest
names we've come up with so far
i'm broke as a joke
you took my boy away from me give me
back my shot sweetie pie hole come on
gary clarkson you're just a junkie
small town cop who had a really bad week
took one too many pills this time but
once you get locked into a serious drug
collection
the tendency is to push it as far as you
can look everything that's happened here
and everything is gonna happen they
don't talk about
you won't weld back
you didn't see anything
i still think we should stick to the
chief's plan oh hell let's just do it we
always do hijack some nuclear weapons
and hold the world hostage
i don't feel so good